[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في حي قاسم باشا الشعبي باسطنبول وبين
اسره محافظه انتقلت من ولايه ريزا شمال
شرقي البلاد بهدف توفير حياه افضل
لاطفالها ولد الطفل رجب طيب اردوغان وبين
ازقتها الضيقه نشا وترعرع ولعب كره القدم
[موسيقى]
من صفاته العناد والمواجهه وعدم الاستسلام
بسهوله نحدثكم عن احد ابرز سياسي تركيا في
القرن الاخير يرى فيه خصومه منافسا شرسا
لا يتوانى عن اقتناص الفرص لهزيمتهم اذ
حقق 15 نصرا انتخابيا على مدى عقدين في
حين يراه مؤيدوه سياسيا محنكا يجيد امساك
العصا من وسطها في علاقاته الخارجيه
وقائدا نجح في مواجهه رموز العلمانيه التي
لم يسبق ان تجرا احد قبله على الاقتراب
منها
درس الثانويه في مدرسه الائمه والخطباء
بطلب من والده ثم تعلم في كليه العلوم
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه في جامعه مرمره في
مراهقته عرف عنه شغفه بكره القدم وانضم
الى فريق ايروكس بورد وهو في الرابعه عشره
من عمره فلعب قرابه 17 عاما في فرق مختلفه
وكاد يحترف في فريق فنار بخشا الشهير
بابا غرامه
من لاعب في ساحات كره القدم التي اعتزلها
نزولا عند رغبه والده الى لاعب في ميدان
السياسه رود العسكر وحكم اكثر من عشرين
سنه متواصله مرحبا
بدا ارض
غمسيه عضوا في حزب السلامه الوطني
نجم الدين اربكان عام
1972 لكنه اضطر الى الابتعاد في اعقاب
الانقلاب العسكري عام
1980 وعاد مع تاسيس اربكان حزب الرفاه في
عام
فانتخب عضوا في مجلس القرار المركزي للحزب
1985 ثم رئيسا لبلديه اسطنبول عام
1994 حاصدا
25%.6 من اصوات الناخبين وهو ما اقد مضجع
التيار العلماني في تركيا الذي بدا يثير
مخاوف الشعب من صعود الاسلاميين في البلاد
[موسيقى]
لما نجم اردوغان خلال رئاسته لبلديه
اسطنبول الكبرى اذ حقق انجازات النوعيه
اكسبته شعبيه كبيره تاره يظهر وهو يقود
شاحنات البلديات بنفسه واخرى يشرف على
تطوير نظام مياه الصرف الصحي والبنيه
التحتيه حتى تحولت اسطنبول من مدينه
تملاها النفايات الى مدينه نظيفه ومنظمه
[موسيقى]
ولكن قبل ان يكمل اردوغان مدته المحدده
بخمس سنوات ادين عام
1998 بتهمه التحريض على الكراهيه الدينيه
والسبب قصيده القاها في ولايه سرت وسط حشد
جماهري كبير
في عام
1999 اقسي اردوغان عن الحياه السياسيه
ومكث في السجن قرابه اربعه اشهر على اثر
محاكمه نقلتها حينها وسائل الاعلام
التركيه فاثار بدفاعه عن نفسه حفيظه
الاوساط العلمانيه ونال اعجاب المواطنين
بسببه
في الرابعه عشره من اب اغسطس 2001 اعلن
تاسيس حزب العداله والتنميه مع عدد من
اصدقائه مؤكدا ان حزبه سيحافظ على اسس
النظام الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
يرى خبراء ان اردوغان انتهج سياسه نجح من
خلالها في تحقيق مكانه دوليه لتركيا فهو
في نظرهم طور اسلوبا دبلوماسيا جديدا في
السياسه الخارجيه وانتقل من سياسه الجمود
الى الحركه الدائمه والتواصل مع جميع
البلدان وكان للشرق الاوسط النصيب الاكبر
من تلك السياسه اذ بدا ظهور الدور التركي
في اكثر القضايا المحوريه يزداد تدريجيا
بعد غياب وعزله طويله بدات منذ اعلان
الجمهوريه التركيه في عهد اتاتورك
حظ يا اردوغان بشهره عالميه واسعه وخصوصا
لدى شريحه كبيره من الشعوب العربيه رات في
سياساته تناغما بين الاعتزاز بالهويه
الاسلاميه مع محاولات مواكبه الحداثه
والنهضه الاقتصاديه لكن مع الخطوات
التركيه الاخيره تجاه دمشق التي بررتها
انقره بترتيب اوضاع اللاجئين والعوده
الطوعيه لاعداد منهم بعد عشر سنوات يترقب
اللاجئ السوري لهذه الخطوات بقلق وخشيه من
مستقبل قد يعرضه للمسائله السياسيه في
بلاده
[موسيقى]
دعا اردوغان مرارا الى اعاده هيكله مجلس
الامن الدولي مطلقا عباره العالم اكبر من
خمسه اعتراضا منه على جعل مصير دول العالم
بيد خمس دول فقط
تصادف وصول اردوغان الى الحكم بمرور بلاده
بازمه ماليه حاده بين عامي
و2 بسبب قروض صندوق النقد الدولي التي
تلقتها في عهد حكومه بولند اجاويد فارتفع
حجم الديون الخارجيه والعجز في الميزانيه
واغلقت الاف الشركات التجاريه وانخفض
الاستثمار لكن اردوغان قدم رؤيته لحل
الازمه قبل الانتخابات واستطاع ان يحقق
انجازات اقتصاديه كبيره جدا بعد ان فتح
ابواب بلاده امام المستثمرين الاجانب
فارتفع دخل الفرد السنوي من
3500 دولار في عام 2002 الى
10,655 دولارا في عام 2022
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
رغم معارضه شرائح معتبره من الطبقه
السياسيه في البلاد سعى اردوغان الى تغيير
اليه الحكم في البلاد من النظام البرلماني
الى النظام الرئاسي بدعوى انه الاكثر
ملائمه لوضع تركيا وحل مشكلاتها واجرى
استفتاء في عام 2017 في تعديل دستوري يؤسس
للنظام الرئاسي وبموافقه اكثر الاتراك على
التعديل اصبح عام 2018 اول رئيس ينتخبه
الشعب في النظام الجديد
في 20 شباط فبراير عام 2018 عقد اردوغان
تحالفا مع زعيم حزب الحركه القوميه دوله
بهشيلي وفي حزيران يونيو عام 2022 اعلنت
ترشحه باسم التحالف للانتخابات الرئاسيه
المزمع عقدها في الرابعه عشر من ايار مايو
2023 في رايك هل ينجح اردوغان في تتويج
مسيرته السياسيه بفوز لولايه ثانيه
[موسيقى]